je défie des élèves de philo d'avoir lu
entièrement post l'enfant turbulent qui
est tout le temps à courir et albat dans
la rue et puis à celui qui se met dans
sa combi moi je te les deux mais je me
battais pas dans la rue parce que dans
les rues de neuilly les enfants ne se
mettent pas je devais avoir 7 ans je
crois j'ai reçu un cadeau somptueux qui
étaient les condamne vercel illustré par
gustave doré terrifiant c'était
terrifiant et je me demande
enfin dans quelle mesure on doit donner
un livre comme ça y est tous les comptes
d'asnières 7 y compris les plus les plus
philosophiques que je comprenais pas
bien sûr et puis alors les plus
terrifiants avec des illustrations les
cimetières les sorcières les fantômes et
ça vraiment je me faisais peur avec et
je savais que j'allais me faire peur et
il m'arrive d'y repenser enfin avec
frayères comme je peux penser à certains
films qui nous fait peur quand j'étais
petit je crois que le premier à la
première rencontre
important qu'un seul grand amour il n'y
a pas de question quand même des actes
qui ont vraiment parlé de ski j'ai parlé
ce point ça il ya eu une période comme
ça ces nébuleuses avec des lectures
alors ça c'est l'époque fit enfin
l'époque
l'adolescente qui lie poussière qu'il y
a
notamment devant
diego a oui toutes les phillies
poussière aux amandes des mains des
garçons de l'isthme je crois que c'est
illisible relie enfin j'ai pas essayé
je défie des élèves de philo d'avoir lu
entièrement post on en lit des morceaux
choisis on l'est commente cassé après
pendant vingt ans on peut dire dans les
salons il faudra que je relis au souffle
il faut dire parce que dit on voit que
leurs livres alors que très peu de gens
comme lui alors ouais à force de prendre
en flagrant délit de dire comme ça dans
les soirées mondaines ils vont rester je
relise il ya deux ans quand même l'élu
et cela dure un mois et demi s'est
terminé alors les deux grands les deux
grands morceaux qui sont le vrai choc et
qui sont responsables de d'une bonne
partie de ce que je suis en bien ou en
mal
c'est les thibault et bien entendu sur
les conditions pour un
jeune citoyen français lire les thibault
et la condition est fini avec thibault
en juin 40
ça conditionne toute une vie je crois
vraiment que ça que ça a été un déclic
formidable dans ma façon de penser ma
façon de voir les choses mais tous les
cinq ans je me refais les thibault
complètement parce que on évolue en et
en changeant de change tout chose mais
ça reste formidable c'est à dire que à
chaque nouvelle relecture je découvre
des choses que j'avais pas et puis alors
la condition quoi que soit la condition
à la relecture je ne sais pas si ça
ferait plaisir rouge sais rien je pense
que je suis pas la seule à lui dire ils
les responsables entièrement de
l'engagement d'une certaine génération
vers une certaine gauche
qu'il le veuille ou non enfin c'est
comme ça et pas autrement
alors vous avez découvert les américains
c'est à dire hemingway steinbeck
tous en tous sens groupe la hemingway
steinbeck en mélangeant un peu enfin je
faisais pas tellement la différence
entre qu'elle doit les faux clair c'est
dire que j'ai tout absorbé comme ça en
plus il faut le dire car ça compte aussi
ces choses là c'était la guerre ses
occupations et c'était dans une denrée
rare
vraiment un médical n'était pas
précisément sur les marchés alors il y
avait aussi un côté je pense si je vais
te fenêtre une espèce de besoin de lire
des choses défendu lui certainement bien
avant de découvrir cela que je n'ai
finalement découvrir qu'il ya dix ans
mais quand j'étais jeune aux aulas était
pas tellement aux conseillers afin sûr
ça te un peu de littérature soit disant
bon marché ce but là mensonge total
c'est admirable puis en plus c'est très
réconfortant de se dire qu'on lit les
livres généreux de monsieur qui était
aussi généreux dans sa vie
[Musique]